la ciudad de nikolaife en el
suroccidente de Ucrania ha sido tal vez
la ciudad más atacada desde el comienzo
de la guerra y por muchos meses la
población no tuvo agua lo que hacía casi
imposible cocinar la organización
que ha venido ayudando a los ucranianos
desde el comienzo creó una alternativa y
es este camión con una cocina interior
donde preparan miles de platos Cada día
que hoy también están repartiendo
usualmente repartimos almuerzos pero si
hay algún problema de Electricidad o gas
les damos comida dos o tres veces todo
depende Si las personas no pueden
cocinar
cocinamos platos diferentes todos los
días para que la gente no tenga la misma
comida
en esta cocina se llegan a preparar
hasta 10
.000 labras lo interesante es que está
preparada para cocinar para personas
mayores que son la mayoría que habitan
Nicolás Así que toda la cocina se hace
con un sistema de vapor o al horno
cumpleaños desde el comienzo de la
guerra no tenía motivación para trabajar
y cuando me invitaron a hacer parte del
proyecto dije porque no hacerlo decidí
aceptarlo y me ha ayudado a salir de un
estado de depresión
[Música]
hay ahora mismo mucha gente mayor porque
la gente joven está fuera del país o en
otra ciudad y mucha gente mayor necesita
nuestra ayuda muchos no tienen la
capacidad de cocinar para ellos mismos o
no tienen dinero suficiente para comprar
productos
este fin de semana Los ucranianos
recuerdan la hambruna que les impuso
Joseph stalin entre 1932 y 1933 en la
que millones de personas murieron
jóvenes como estos de miko Life que
decidieron quedarse dicen que con este
trabajo en esta organización están
ayudando especialmente a personas
mayores a que no corran la misma suerte